there is no real Central Perk in New
York but it did inspire some real-life
cafes because of course friends is a
worldwide phenomenon it just blows my
mind in China as I think about how big
this shows about a house button we're
car like oh good they're interested in
the hair and all right okay fine every
wants to know that's great it does come
as a surprise to me that people finding
me a sex symbol on that Brad Pitt huh
we actually became really popular this
summer after it aired them and then we
did reruns in the summer I think that's
when we really took off we've arrived
arrived and still here making Bank each
friend reportedly pulls down a cool 20
million dollars a year thanks to reruns
and get this the new streaming service
HBO max just shelled out 425 million for
the right to start running the show
exclusively next year great so what made
it such a success for starters we all
wanted to be friends with the friends
[Music]
Vegas this weekend gamble Jack and we
went and it was too fun there was a lot
of bonding no it's pretty much all I can
say about it and we were obsessed with
their real-life romances when Courtney
married David Arquette in 1999 producers
jokingly changed everyone's name in the
credits Jen made headlines when she
married Brad Pitt in 2000 really got
that sexy smoldering thing going on this
2001 guest starring role on the show
head of the I hate Rachel Green Club
he's trying to mount something to me
Matthew day Julia Roberts with
everything they met when she guessed it
on the show in 1995 have you ever worn
women's underwear it was so much fun it
was utterly nerve-wracking
I was so nervous I was so nervous the
throw up factor was high high high and
then there was that time the friends
made TV history but the joke's on you
it was the second season of the show
when they found out they weren't all
making the same salary so they all went
on strike and they all got raises we
wanted to be paid the same things we
thought that was fair and putting in the
same amount of work and it was kind of
something we believed in that solidarity
ultimately got them a million dollars
per episode her friend for the last two
seasons of the show
I remember our director Jim burrows sat
us down and said you got to really watch
out for each other cuz this is gonna be
something big and we're gonna get you
seated I've heard that before but he was
right and we really have done that and
it is it's a phenomenon
[Music]